each year the Serengeti plains in
Tanzania play host to one of the
greatest animal migrations on earth some
2 million animals begin a round trip
that will take them almost 2,000 miles
fossil evidence suggests that modern
wildebeest grazed these Plains more than
a million years ago at the beginning of
each year the wildebeest congregate on
the fringes of the Serengeti all giving
birth in the same month rapidly their
numbers swell the calves can run as fast
as their mothers within two days of
being born no one knows what triggers
the migration there is no discernable
signal it just takes one or two to sniff
the air and decide the time is right to
leave the migrating animals journey is a
long and arduous one even without the
attention of predators around 200,000 of
the weakest wildebeest and zebras will
die from starvation disease or over
exertion during the trek every day fresh
carcasses are left behind the migrating
animals rest at the swollen streams and
regroup
a single cat finds it tricky to bring
down a full-grown wildebeest but if it
can separate a wildebeest calf all from
its mother then it has a chance of a
meal
Hey
in Kenya's Masai Mara the migrating
herds arrived rains have created a huge
area of well watered grazing here the
wildebeest will stay until the smell of
November short rains tell them it's time
to regroup and head southwards back
towards the Serengeti